[music]
>> Spices are often far pricier
proportionately than the foods they
flavor, [music]
but one's cost has long topped them all.
Saffron's [music] red threads regularly
run at rates over $600
an ounce. So, why is this so-called red
gold so expensive?
Spices come from [music] different plant
parts. Saffron is the only one made of
flower stigmas. They're plucked from a
flowering plant called a crocus.
Different crocus species [music]
dot countrysides across Eurasia and
North Africa, and it appears that humans
began harvesting wild crocuses quite a
way back.
Ancient cave paintings in what's now
[music] Iraq derived colors from crocus
pigments.
However, this paint was probably created
with a different [music] type of crocus
because it's thought that the saffron
crocus developed [music]
relatively recently when a single wild
crocus produced a seed
>> [music]
>> carrying an extra set of chromosomes.
This mutation resulted in a flower with
especially [music]
long stigmas that packed high
concentrations of three compounds of
interest: crocin, [music] which lends
saffron its vibrant hue and makes an
effective dye, picrocrocin, [music]
which gives saffron its characteristic
taste, and saffronal, which imparts its
hay-like aroma.
The plant's added chromosomes also made
it sterile, so it could have simply come
and gone from the face of the Earth
pretty quickly. But scientists think
that people long ago recognized this
unique crocus qualities.
And while it couldn't reproduce sexually
[music] by seed, it could spread through
its corm, an underground stem-like plant
organ that can asexually [music]
generate new growth.
It seems people began propagating it
themselves, separating and cultivating
new corm growths.
Today's commercial saffron comes from
crocuses that are all functionally twins
from this single clonal line. Scientists
think the original plant first emerged
in southern [music] Greece. Exactly when
is unclear, but over 3,500
year-old Greek frescos depict women
harvesting the spice.
And saffron fields in modern-day Iran
seem to trace back at [music] least
3,000 years.
Before long, ancient Persian people were
stirring the spice into foods,
freshening up with saffron-infused
perfume, and draping [music] themselves
in saffron-tinged fabrics.
Ancient Greeks spread the spices
sensuous smell in courts, theaters, and
baths.
And in 4th [music] century BCE Persia,
Alexander the Great became smitten with
saffron and recommended it in baths to
treat battle wounds.
Legend says Cleopatra likewise achieved
glowing skin from soaking in the spice.
And around the 9th century, Islamic
rulers lavished each other with saffron
gifts during prisoner exchanges and
other diplomatic ventures.
Persian physician Ibn Sina included
saffron in his Canon of Medicine circa
1025 as an aphrodisiac and treatment for
ailments like depression, asthma, and
inflammation. Meanwhile, a Tibetan text
boasted saffron's immune-strengthening
and beauty-intensifying [music] powers.
In 1300s Europe, saffron was a purported
antidote to the plague.
Many of these historical accounts of
saffron's health benefits don't hold up
or are overblown, but saffron has indeed
proved to have anti-inflammatory [music]
and antioxidant properties.
In medieval Nuremberg, the [music]
government appointed inspectors to check
for saffron fraud and dole out
punishments [music]
as extreme as the death penalty. While
in the early 1700s, settlers brought
saffron to North America, where it
fetched the same price as gold at the
Philadelphia exchange. Saffron's pricey
preciousness, then and now, comes down
to its production. Most of the work
required to produce [music] saffron is
squeezed into the crocuses' roughly
two-week flowering window. Workers often
begin at dawn, hand-picking the
crocuses, usually before they blossom to
prevent wilting and preserve [music]
potency. Then, they pluck the three
stigmas from each flower and dry them.
They must process [music] around 150,000
flowers, the equivalent of over 400
hours of labor, to produce a single
kilogram of saffron.
A little goes a long way in what have
become some of saffron's [music]
signature dishes, a few threads infusing
whole trays of tahchin, pans of paella,
and bowls of bouillabaisse. [music]
But the spice's price has stayed
astronomical. Over generations, [music]
farmers have selectively bred many other
domesticated crops [music] to maximize
yields and other desirable traits.
However, because saffron crocuses
[music]
are all sterile clones, they've remained
largely unchanged, as have [music] their
labor-intensive, low stigma yields.
Some researchers [music] are
investigating experimentally inducing
mutations,
but environmental instability has made
harvests increasingly unreliable,
threatening the saffron crop and the
traditional livelihoods that have
painstakingly kept the miraculous mutant
alive for [music] millennia.
Ready to keep learning? Watch these
videos to either challenge what you
think you know, or learn more about what
you don't. Subscribe and stay curious.
>> [music]